is the air quality around Ground Zero a
hazard yes the indoor air quality is
undoubtedly a hazard in many places the
problem is since the proper testing
hasn't done we don't know how many
places we don't know how many thousands
or tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands of people are being slowly
poisoned by contaminated workspaces and
schools and apartments as the Inspector
General recommended we ought to do
proper endure testing in going out in
concentric circles from the World Trade
Center we may find that in one direction
the problem is three blocks we may find
that in other directions three miles and
then we have to systematically and
properly clean up decontaminate those
apartments and workspaces testimony damn
woodsman hearing a year and a half ago
said that the average cost of
decontaminated properly an apartment
would be between ten and twenty thousand
dollars per apartment / apartment and
who would pay for them federal
government its mandate under law tell us
about the initial government response to
dealing with the air quality surrounding
the World Trade Center after the attacks
well the initial government response was
was frankly terrible and and what I what
I what I'm about to say the everything
I'm about to say came out and inspector
general's report but everything I'm
about to say everything that was in the
inspector general's report was not new I
had been saying it for almost two years
environmental groups have been saying it
others have been saying it the
Ombudsman's office after of EPA said it
and because they said it Christy Todd
Whitman dismantled the Ombudsman's
office destroyed the office the only
thing new in there in the IG report was
that the misrepresentations and lies
that the EPA told us we're done at the
direction of the White House that we
didn't know everything else was quite
well known to people who were looking
into it and of course was officially
denied by the EPA and the administration
but also meticulously documented first
thing that happened was within two days
of the disaster Christy Todd Whitman
went on the air and said that the head
of the EPA went on the air and said that
the air was safe to breathe
New Yorkers could go back to work
without worrying about it when she said
that there had been zero testing done
she had no basis and data to say that
she kept saying it the EPA kept saying
it even after there was at first sketchy
and then voluminous data to say that the
air was far from safe for example the
University of California Davis headed by
a fella named Thomas I think his first
name cahill setup instruments on the
roof of the federal building at varick
and Houston Street the building my
office is in which is a mile north of
ground zero they did this on october
third about three weeks after nine
eleven and those instruments stay then
they kept getting readings at least
through the end of january and we knew
by a october third or fourth they told
us they told the epa they told anybody
who would listen that the reading is a
mile north of ground zero three weeks
afterwards were the were the worst
cocktail brew of toxins they'd ever seen
worse than the Kuwaiti oil fire that was
the direct quote at the time and that
was true at least as late as as late
January 2002 the outdoor area
nonetheless that we kept getting all
these reassurances that everything was
okay on the basis of which people told
their employees you got to come back to
work even though the air is unsafe
because they believed the EPA says over
the air was safe on the base of which
schools reopened in the area and parents
were told it's okay we had testimony
recently at a press conference from a
doctor at Mount Sinai at Long expert who
said that who's a pediatrician who said
that he told hundreds of parents that
was okay to send the kids back to school
he relied on the EPA assurances he
wished he hadn't done because he now has
the qualities people say the kids had
better be examined because the air was
not safe based on those assurances we
know that hunt that many many
of the first responders the cops the
fire fighters from all over the country
didn't use respirators we also know that
the contrary to what the Christy Todd
Whitman has said many of them were not
given respirators many were told don't
wear respirators many were told to wear
respirators and some did of course the
respirators clunky very difficult to
work with and while the EPA was saying
in the fine print you should wear a
respirator that was shouting from the
housetops of the air was safe so as a
mixed message as a result of which many
people who could have used the
respirators didn't something like over
seventy percent of the first responders
at this point have shown already serious
lung abnormalities and of one sort or
another and all the data we kept getting
in kept telling us this was very toxic
now the EPA started lying about it as I
said and then in the aiji's reported
shows now Christy Todd Whitman I saw her
on television saying the White House
just co-ordinated they didn't coordinate
if you look at some of the press
releases the EPA draft and then what was
released after the White House got
through with it you see the difference
i'll mention two that were in the IG
report specifically one said words to
the effect of twenty-five percent of the
outdoor tests show highly elevated two
and three times the safe level or the
recommended level limit of asbestos in
the air twenty-five percent of the tests
show unsafe levels of his bestest in the
air that was the drift when the White
House got through with it came out with
the vast majority of tests show only
safe levels of asbestos which was true
seventy-five percent didn't find it but
twenty-five percent found highly
dangerous levels of asbestos so from a
warning you change it into don't worry
and she says that's that's minor editing
the other another one that I recall from
the aiji's report was the initial draft
said if you're going to remove asbestos
or material world trade center debris in
your apartment whatever make sure you
wear protective clothing it came out
publicly without any mention of
protective clothing those are very
significant differences in any event we
started shouting on October for we
retained ie formed a coalition of all
the law
elected officials two days after ground
zero we retain a we called it the ground
zero elected officials test for us we
retained a private environmental
consulting firm to do a spot checking to
test a few indoor apartments because the
EPA was only doing outdoor tests and
they came back highly toxic the report
was published on october fourteenth a
month after 911 we handed this report to
EPA we publicized it an EPA kept saying
nothing except that things are safe
there was subsequent testing of indoor
air nothing was done about indoor air
until in the Senate hearings that
Hillary Clinton that my suggestion got
Joe Lieberman to call in January of 2002
fight was at five months after Ground
Zero that was the first time the EPA
commented on indoor air and they said
where is we the EPA we're responsible
for the outdoor yet not for the indoor
at the city of New York took the lead on
that now they are responsible by law for
indoor and outdoor area the law makes no
distinction and of course what happened
in the indoor air and this is why the
problem is not a question of who lied
when wine who is responsible that that
is a problem but it's the less important
the problem more important problem is
that nature cleans the outdoor air
nature does not clean the indoor air I'm
not worried about the air quality
outdoors today I am worried about the
air quality indoors because EPA kept
denying that there was a problem indoors
they never did proper testing indoors
they didn't do any kind of cleanup for
indoors until may of 2002 when they
announced that for PR purposes
everything's fine they said but to allay
public concern meaning for public
relations purposes we will clean up
apartments upon request apartments not
work spaces or schools or firehouses
upon request which means if you're in
apartment 3a and you ask them to clean
it up and they do and assuming they do a
decent job your apartments going to get
Rican Taman ated through the HVAC system
from apartment 3b that wasn't cleaned up
yet the head of the building as a whole
they assume that there was a Star Trek
type force field at Canal Street so only
below Canal Street not across the river
we know that that places in Brooklyn and
New Jersey were also contaminated they
used only active to any only passive
testing with
tests designed to show negative because
they use the large what's called large
filters which means the ultrafine
particles that are the most dangerous
and that came out of the highly
pulverized World Trade Center wouldn't
register on their tests let's all these
things the IG said so their cleanup
program was worthless and as the IG said
we have to do a proper cleanup program
now let me just say this observation
they'll go to whatever you want to say
we I would say there are three victim
populations today other than the people
killed directly by the terrorists one
are those people caught in the cloud on
911 it's note nobody's today they
inhaled an acute dose of god knows what
every toxin known to man many of them
have gotten sick many will there's
nothing we can do for them other than
money to them and give them whatever
health treatment we can it's nobody's
fault other than terrorists secondly are
the hundreds maybe thousands of first
responders emergency workers who because
of mixed messages or false messages from
EPA or non availability of respirators
worked on the prowl for forty fifty days
without proper protection many of whom
have gotten sick many of whom will get
sick again we it's past tense you can
only try to help them in the future but
someone will be held accountable third
and perhaps most importantly the
thousands maybe tens of thousands maybe
hundreds of thousands of people being
slowly poisoned today but not by acute
doses by small chronic doses of asbestos
lead cadmium zinc mercury every day
because they're working or living in
unsafe work spaces or living spaces and
the point about that is having done that
for a year and a half or two years some
of them will cut some of these people
will come down with lung cancer
mesothelioma or other life-threatening
diseases 15 years from now but if this
continues for another 15 years without
cleaning it up many many more will so if
we clean it up now we can save many
lives and the last thing is if we don't
clean it up I am very much afraid that
50 years from now when the historian's
right about this they will write that
more people died early from preventable
diseases you know within the next 20
years then were killed by the terrorists
on 911 Sacramento California thank you
very much for holding
it s good morning I don't know if I'm
saying your name right is it is it Nader
Ripa's and resonators no nadler net
learn no relations or else no matter and
that look scuze me I mean I can
appreciate what you're saying and I do
understand but I think that you're going
across lines here in a way that you're
saying that the EPA report came out and
when I'm understanding what miss Clinton
represents senator Clinton and Lieberman
was saying was just plain and simple
they were lying to us well they were
lying to you they were lying to me and
I'm but I'm but to get off that you're
also saying step above justice a bestest
and the insight okay that probably was
already there prior to nine and eleven
no no no let me let me say this we have
there been scientific investigations by
by environmental teams hired by ten
inside by private organizations the
World Trade Center is bet these vessels
with which the World Trade Center was
built is of a certain type i think it's
called Christmas tile or something like
that there are various types of his best
as it came into it came by the way from
a town called from a mine in Libby
Montana where there was a disaster a
couple years ago um that has been
identified in many of the buildings with
dust and debris from the World Trade
Center but it's not just as bestest its
lead it's cadmium it's zinc it's mercury
it's all kinds of hydrocarbons or all
kinds of things all of which none all of
which most many of which are toxic and
the effect of which when combined the
synergistic effects we don't know has
never happened before saratoga springs
new york you're on with representative
nadler yes good morning wind of nadler i
want you to know i'm a registered
democrat and have been for years I'm 75
at this point and I tell you you speak
in generalities you name a doctor you
don't name a doctor you quote a doctor
from Mount Sinai Hospital well maybe if
you weren't as well named steve levin
he's the head 11 steve levin a while and
i read anything in the paper by mr. or
doc
he's billion 11 he's been in the paper
in the papers a lot I was born and
raised in New York City before you were
born and I tell you very frankly the
city has always had a tremendous order
it's getting worse and it has been
getting worse before nine eleven you're
trying to lay all this environmental
stuff on the current administration when
if you want to really go back to EPA and
what a farce it really is you can go
back to the Clinton today administration
it look I'm the wait a minute wait a
minute you let me finish because I give
you the courtesy of when you speak I
listen I've listened to you in Congress
and very frankly I don't particularly
care for your methods I very frankly I
never changed parties but I'm unburden
doing that because thanks for your call
let me let me say this first of all new
is a lot cleaner than it was decades ago
and a lot of that the the credit for
that belongs to Republican Nelson
Rockefeller did some environmental bond
issues New York is much cleaner and then
it was decades ago with that question
I'm not laying the blame for all the
environmental pollution in New York and
the Bush administration or anybody else
but what I am saying is that the
response and it's not just knee
everybody who has looked at this
honestly ascenso the EPA Ombudsman said
so and they dismantled his office
because of that the EPA IG has looked
said so and that's what we're quoting
from most of it and there's plenty of
chapter in verse said we don't have much
time here I could to go into all the
specifics although i'll go into any
specifics you anybody wants but the
facts of the matter are is and I spoke
about some of the specific failings of
the so-called cleanup program I go into
more why don't we take this call from
Long Branch New Jersey go ahead good
morning gentlemen how are you today I'm
going to start by saying bushes worst
president in my history and I'm 50 and I
I'm Frank loans by congressman and I am
a volunteer for him and I'm very proud
of that coming I know I think so thank
you um coming from new jersey i could
tell you Christie Whitman's history and
it's not good and to be I'm not
surprised at all that
Bush administration would have her lie
about the outcome of the whole thing
because now we have our country is of
the corporation by the corporation why
the corporation and it just is the whole
thing is making me sexy honest with you
I don't have I don't really have a
question for you but I you really have a
big fight on your hands well thank you
and let me just say this the question of
who lied and so forth is an important
question but the more important question
which I keep trying to shift the
emphasis to the press wants to say who
lied and when and we know that Christy
Whitman the EPA light and the white
house apparently directed that according
to the IG but the more important thing
is to get a proper clean up to do the
test the spot checking in indoor
environments and concentric circles are
out from the World Trade Center in
Brooklyn and Queens in New Jersey we
know the ash fell there too in Manhattan
and find out where that problem is and
then do a proper cleanup spend a half a
billion or a billion or whatever is
necessary to do a proper cleaner so that
15 years from now we don't have
thousands of people coming down with
with all kinds of life-threatening
illnesses and so that 15 years from now
we don't have tens of billions of
dollars of lawsuits against the federal
state and city government which we will
have it the way things are going Los
Angeles go ahead they have those
lawsuits anyway those trial lawyers are
your biggest unit you're not gonna help
wait a minute don't you get let me guess
that you can have a lot fewer lawsuits a
fewer people get sick go ahead Los
Angeles may I speak yeah thank your
point k you're not telling people but
these are Clinton holdovers in the EPA
and that you need to keep the
environmentalists on your site and
hitting Republicans forever we were
under attack mr. Nadler you just said
that for 40 or 50 days firemen could get
mapped working on the town I'll that
sort of blatant why that is I'm sorry it
happens to be true some of them couldn't
get miss you talked to the United
firefighters association the basis for
my statement was I was testimony at the
Ombudsman's hearings by a reserve a
reservist and military intelligence is
also a cop not a firefighter who said
that 800 people that he worked with had
not been able to get the respirators
that was his sworn testimony
and the fact is you know this coil it
was a perfect example of what the
administration's response has been he
didn't deal with the facts he simply
questioned at my motives he said that I
wanted to attack the administration or
whatever and that the people who report
and that the IG and the people of
Clinton holdovers yes the Inspector
General of the EPA actually is not a
Clinton hold obviously was there she's
been the vpa her apparently for four
decades from prior to clean she was
appointed by during the Clinton
administration she was appointed
inspector general and during the Bush
administration she was reappointed
inspector general so and the implication
that just because someone was in
government during the clinton
ministration means they dishonesty can't
trust them she was reappointed by bush
and again as I said the Ombudsman said
this the inspector general said this
damn Bushman's office was was dismantled
because they had the nurse to say it so
I hope that people if they want to
dispute the facts dispute the facts on
some basis for this beaut the logic but
don't just say you're a Democrat
therefore what you're saying is
politically motivated just talk about
the facts Sebring Florida go ahead hello
mr. Nadler thank you so much for for
bringing these issues out into the
public this administration has been so
secretive about everything they don't
think that the American people have the
wherewithal or the mental capacity to
understand what's going on in the
country i think i'm just sick to death
about this train wreck of a presidency
has ruined our country and thank you
thank you for all the work you've done
and that you're doing well you're
welcome but again the main thing here is
not where the bush is a good of a bad
president that mental thoughts on that
you can guess what they are the main
thing here is to get a proper testing
and cleanup done in the new york area
yes we were attacked by terrorists but
we don't we shouldn't want to magnify
the effect of what the terrorists did by
letting people live and work in unsafe
environments for a few decades so that
many many more people have their lives
shortened by the results of what the
terrorists did then if we cleaned it up
properly and that's the most important
thing right now to get a proper
investigation in a prime I don't mean an
investigation we did why
proper testing regimen and a proper
cleanup decontamination program so that
the so that we save lives now let me say
well give one example of this the New
York City Department of Health put on
its website this is not just the Bush
administration's every level of
government and the executive branch
we're almost as culpable the New York
City Department of Health put on its
website as far as I know it's still
there and if you come back into your
apartment you find World Trade Center
dust and debris clean it up with a wet
mop and wet rag and if it's really bad
wear long pants and consider HEPA vacuum
now that advice is reckless endangerment
because if you clean if you're not
trained prompt now first of all illegal
advice federal state law both say that
if there's at best as bestest late
material anywhere no one may remove it
or move it or deal with it unless
they're licensed and certified to do so
and wearing proper protective equipment
which most people in their apartments
are not secondly it's dangerous if you
start removing that yourself you're
going to breathe in some of it and
equally importantly you may remove a lot
of it but a lot of it is going to go
into the porous wood surfaces into the
into the carpet into the drapes and
every time you walk on that carpet or
the baby crawls on it a little of it is
going to be pushed into the air you're
going to breathe it for the next 20
years tell us about to the brush tell us
about the congressional investigation
that you've called for into the federal
government's efforts on this well we
have called I have called Fred for
outlaw and Nancy Pelosi a democratic
leader in the house joined me and other
Democratic leaders of committees in
calling for house investigations from
the Clinton called for a Senate
investigation I asked the Justice
Department to look into it but what
we've asked for investigation is into
two things number one who told the truth
that didn't tell the truth of
manipulating information in a way that
might lead people to do one say things i
mean the initial response and number two
an investigation into whether in fact a
proper
testing and decontamination program is
necessary now Hoffman Heights Colorado
go ahead Hoffman Heights sorry nadler
that was an extreme emergency yes it was
and the firefighters rescue people ran
in there to save people's lives they
were given respirators the country was
donating equipment and I mean what if it
happens again what are we going to do
are you and senator Clinton going to go
down to a site and demand that nobody
goes near the scene of an explosion like
that until the air is clean the EPA ters
another law on the books that says it's
illegal to occupy any building with
asbestos are we going to evacuate New
York City for the next 30 years and your
solution well let me in to go first I'm
not aware of that law that it's illegal
to occupy any building with his bestest
I don't know of any such law but second
of all it's illegal to build a building
now with asbestos and it's illegal to
remove existing as bestest or to repair
things around the asbestos without
taking proper precaution Airy measures
wearing protective clothing and being
licensed to certify that you know what
you're doing um no certainly we're not
going to urge people not to go in there
and yes it was an extreme emergency and
I don't criticize anybody for what for
for not wearing respirators or not
providing respirators or or whatever
during the first few days afterwards but
by the time a few days passed three four
five six days a week [ __ ] I don't know
some amount of time you should have
gotten organized and provided the
respirators the testimony we had at the
Ombudsman hearings in March of last year
with that 800 police officers and police
cadets worked on the pile for 41 days
without respirators be though they asked
for them they were totally went
unavailable although again the testimony
said that there were thousands lying
unused the National Guard armories all
around the city and its vicinity I
suppose what I would recommend is that
protective respirators be more widely
available distributed to fire houses and
police precincts and so forth so that in
case god forbid of another emergency
they have the more readily available but
I'm not criticizing anybody for what
they did in terms of the emergency
response in the first few days but after
they got organized properly and and it
was a major cleanup job it was a debris
removal job wasn't even a rescue job
because after when you knew the
temperatures and they were 800 degrees
you knew nobody was alive after the
first few days then it was simply a
debris removal job you should have done
it with proper safety precautions which
very often we know now weren't done and
I'm critical of the EPA not for not
having respirators there right away that
wasn't within the capability but for
giving out misinformation which caused
many people not to use the respirators
that they had Lancaster Pennsylvania
you're on the Washington journal oh
thank you representative nadler I
followed you I really appreciate all
that you are doing for your country
thank you um and I actually originally I
didn't have a question until it dawned
on me I have a friend who whose windows
during the terrorist attack were blown
out in their apartment and she's been
trying to get pregnant now and she is
now but she sounds like she's going to
lose the baby do you think these
pollutants could be the cause of that
conceivably I'm not a medical expert but
conceivably I mean she should certainly
see a doctor and talk about that and if
her windows were blown out that means
there was it was close enough to have
considerable force she should get her
apartment tested by a good environmental
testing firm Michael Levitt was in front
of the Senate Environment and Public
Works Committee this week on his
nomination to be the administrator at
EPA senator Clinton says that she would
block that unless the EPA comes forth
with a report reassuring the public
about the safety of the air in New York
City after the World Trade Center
attacks is that a good move on her part
well I think it is i don't think the EPA
can come forward with a with a report
reassuring the public about the safety
yeah I think what she's asking for is an
explanation of what they did and a
proper testing and cleanup program
now I mean to to demand that someone
assure us that the air was okay when it
probably wasn't when it wasn't
definitely wasn't okay this is it's not
doable but yes I think it's very good
that she's doing that I commend her for
doing that because the administration
for whatever reason says has simply
denied everything and and been
stonewalled they've been unable to do
anything